I want to get a chance to talk to
someone who's been in this tournament
and kind of get his thoughts on it we
turn now to Steve live in the Turner
NCAA analyst and former coach at UCLA in
st. John's how are we doing today coach
terrific how you guys doing glad to be
with you glad to be with you I'm still
gonna call you coach everyone's gonna
call you Steve Lavin but once you're a
coach are always a coach to me is that
okay
absolutely you call me lab coach laughs
Steve coach whatever you need see that's
what see that's a player's coach right
there you see that you see how a
player's coach like he won't see like
hey just call me lab okay coach Lavin
coach I had a suggestion and help me out
here what do you think about this that
we changed the name of the NCAA
tournament
it shouldn't be March Madness should be
Final Four
what do you think of us me and you tell
me if you're all in on this to the
sister Jean Invitational oh no doubt
this year she's captivated not only
college basketball fans imagination but
the entire country it all even taken
worldwide the World Cup we'll see you
know certain countries team that
captures the imagination that compelling
stories but hers ranks right up there in
the history of sports 98 years old I got
the rosary beads going its Loyola wins
yes I wouldn't be surprised if the Pope
doesn't let me call that locker room and
doesn't invite Loyola to the vatic
temple they might get a visit to the
White House as well right now her
intellect her quick wit the authentic
and kind of genuine connection that the
team has with her right and she's really
elevated this tournament to kind of a
different level when you think about the
landscape of college basketball right
now coach Steve Lavin joining us here on
the Rich Eisen show coach I'm looking at
the landscape of college basketball and
what the whole one-and-done I I haven't
had the time or the opportunity to
really get to know players so when I
watched the I think the NCAA tournament
the March Madness and I think I'm with a
lot of fans out there
is that we were truly getting our first
look at some of these players but yet
when this Final Four is over where there
is Villanova winning Kansas Michigan or
Loyola Chicago
what will we remember most about this
tournament well I think it's interesting
because these four teams are nice mix
you've got you know a team like oil a
big major program in terms of making a
run at the NC double-a tournament yeah
Michigan who is a strong brand name
though their board football school John
Beilein
has had great success with the
basketball program and going back
Jasmine Trussell
back in the day for the Wolverines and
of course there's that Glen Rice team
they the green run as well national
championship was deep fissures the codes
the fab box there's been other strong
Michigan teams
and a Kansas that goes back to the
history of dr. Naismith dr. Naismith had
an influence on fog Alan Phog Allen had
an influence at Kansas on Dean Smith of
course Dean Smith that influence
montalais ground Larry Brown had an
influence on Bill Self so he talked
about a family tree and going back and
origins of the inventor of basketball
Kansas and then doing over jay wright as
good as it gets
he's built a power house he's making
getting 30 wins a season looks easy
so I think interestingly when you look
at these four teams the upperclassmen
are really the key players we talked
about the one and done and yes freshmen
have an effect like Lonzo ball did last
year chill a in the past Carmelo Anthony
and refreshment let Syracuse to a
championship Mike Bibby has a crashed at
97 lat Arizona in 97 to it to a national
championship but these four teams
actually have upperclassmen they've done
the old school continuity and players
that have helped build the culture
establish a winning way programs
Turner Sports NCAA analyst Steve Lavin
tune into
exclusive coverage of the Final Four
national title games on TBS with
corresponding team cast presentations on
TNT and truTV
you know coach when you think about
where all of these cultures right you
mention it whether it's beeline where
this is Jay Wright Bill Self and you're
just thinking about where these teams
right how do you prepare for this moment
does the experience like the Kansas and
Villanova have or even beeline or how
would you talk to the Loyola Chicago
team what would you tell them about this
moment is it still just hey we're still
underdogs because at some point always
say this you're climbing Mount Everest
right and it's all fun when you're
climbing because you still see the top
of the mountain but at some point if you
look back down you're like are we
supposed to be here so if you're the
coach at Loyola Chicago what would you
say well I think number one you know at
this stage of the season all these teams
have been playing extremely well or they
would be in the Final Four so one of the
keys is not having the departure from
your routines as you know the NFL Major
League Baseball any sport really any
craft musicians or dancers and routine
repetition and so one of the things one
of those popular sporting events in the
world the more you can replicate or
duplicate your routines from pregame
meals to your walkthroughs your video
sessions in those routines I think
that's critical because you're more
likely to perform when you're familiar
and comfortable with the conditions and
the routines that have allowed you to
get to this point also you don't want to
overdo it sometimes younger coaches make
the mistake to try to do too many
adjustments and there's an old coach
named Pete Newell Hall of Famer 1-under
gold medal also an NC double-a title an
ID title you'd say the Hays in the barn
by this stage you can make subtle
adjustments in terms of how you've been
it covered you know in terms of post
offense
handle our cover on ball screens
understand you're making some subtle
adjustments individual personnel you're
getting preparation your drum roll into
the game but you're not going to
automatically change who you are might
have a couple wrinkles within your
offense you know go to learn more
options counters pressure anticipate
what Chiefs may do in terms of their
defensive coverages but I think you know
keeping it simple because you want your
team mentally and physically fresh on
point for competitive great to see coach
willing to find your pennant greatness
be at your best when you're best to need
it so don't over prepare your team
overwork them be mindful of their fuel
both emotional and physical fuel so they
can bring that level of effort that it
takes to win those two beings on a
Saturday Monday to cut down the nudge
from sports n-c-double-a I know Steve
Lavin joining the Rich Eisen so
appreciate the time coach and I'll be
looking for your analytic work this
weekend so have fun okay sounds good
that's coach Steve Lavin or NCAA analyst
for Turner Sports the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience